How's it going and welcome back to
another video. In this video, we are
going to go over the best model for
beginners or anyone starting out. But
also, this is not just for beginners.
This is anyone who is looking to trade.
So, let's get into the video. So, the
first step in this intraday model is
having a daily bias and this is the most
important part. It is anticipating the
daily candle or a daily expansion
candle. How we're going to do that is
using a candle two or a candle three
closure. If you do not know what this
is, please check out my website where I
cover candle two closure and candle
three closure in depth with videos. But
a candle two closure is where we have
price sweep out its previous candle and
close back above it. With this, we can
anticipate the next candle to expand
because reversal then expansion and this
is when we can have a daily bias or look
to trade is when we have an anticipated
expansion candle.
If this candle closes well
or above candle two's high, then we can
also look for a continuation in candle
four.
Now, it is important to note that with a
candle two closure, we do need a change
in the state of delivery inside that
candle two before we can look to trade
that expansion higher. Now, we went over
how to get daily bias with the candle
two closure where we can trade candle
three or candle four. Now, if we don't
have a candle two closure, as you can
see here, price sweeps out its previous
candle but does not close back above it.
This means we can wait for another
candle. We don't have a bias for this
candle. Once this candle prints, it is
engulfing this candle previous if it
closes over its body. That means it is a
candle three closure. With a candle
three closure, then we can look to trade
candle four as price has shown that is
reversed in candle two and is looking
for a continuation higher in candle
four. Now, once again, we do need to
confirm this on the lower time frame
looking for a change in the state of
delivery to have occurred before we're
looking to get on side in candle four.
If there is no change in the state of
delivery, then we cannot look to trade
this. And if you don't know what this
is, I have an entire video on confirming
swing points using the state of delivery
on my website. Now, once we have a daily
bias, this is when we are going to go
down to the four-hour chart. We are
simply looking for the same thing on the
four-hour chart, a candle two or a
candle three closure. In this scenario,
you can see we have a candle two
closure, so we can look to anticipate
candle three, four, and then a continued
expansion if we haven't hit our draw on
liquidity or our higher time frame key
level. So, the goal is to have a daily
bias. In this case, we're going over a
bullish scenario. So, with a bullish
daily bias, we want to see price open,
trade lower to form the wick. Once the
wick has formed, which is what we're
using the four-hour candles for, then we
can look to trade it higher. So, once we
have that candle two closure, what are
we going to look for? We're going to do
the same thing that we just did with the
daily and hourly, but with the four-hour
and 15-minute fractal model. So, if we
zoom in here, once we have a four-hour
candle two closure or candle three
closure, we're going to first check that
we have a what? Change in the state of
delivery. We're going to do that by
finding the low, finding the series of
candles that made that low, and then
once price has closed through that
level, it has confirmed the swing point
and we can look to trade that
continuation higher.
How are we going to trade that
continuation? We're going to look for a
new protected swing. So, what is that?
We need a point of interest, so sweeping
out a low or reaching into a fair value
gap or ideally both. So you can see
here, we're sweeping out all these lows
into this fair value gap. And then price
closes over this series of down closed
candles into that point of interest.
Once we have formed that, we can
anticipate this wick to have formed,
right? So you see how we're doing the
same thing on the higher time frame as
we are on the lower time frame. And we
can look for this to expand higher. So
the goal of this model is to trade
candle three on multiple time frames or
an expansion candle on the daily aligned
with a lower time and fractal model.
With that, we can look for price to
expand higher. So let's get into some
examples in TradingView and go over
this. So here we are with our first
example and you can see we are trading
within a range. We have just taken out
our range low. So we could be looking
for price to trade to our range high,
which also lines up as a fractal model
target.
So with this, we have a candle two
closure on the daily at a point of
interest. So we could be looking for
this to trade higher if we have what? An
hourly change in the state of delivery.
So taking a look here, adding my
indicator on, it shows that we have an
hourly change in the state of delivery
with a green tea spot here. We could be
looking for price to trade higher from
here considering we have that
confirmation of the daily wick. Now
here, I'm going to go to the 4-hour time
frame. So here on the 4-hour time frame,
what am I looking for? I'm looking for a
4-hour swing point within this daily
candle. So let's let this move ahead and
here you can see we'll go ahead and
rewind but we have formed a 4-hour swing
point right here as we have swept out
this previous low as well as had a
candle two closure and this confirmation
here,
which is a new protected swing.
So with that, we can go down to the
15-minute time frame. I'm going to go
ahead and put on this indicator
template, which will show the daily
candle as well as 4-hour candles here.
And we can be looking to trade this
higher here.
So in this candle, we've already opened
up and taken out this high. It's usually
not ideal to long after that as we're
going to get either a consolidation or a
retracement if we're going to continue
higher. So, I'd rather wait to see if we
get one of those. So, I'll go ahead and
remove all these drawings. Let's see
what happens.
Here we are getting that retracement.
So, we can kind of wait until we get
into the New York session.
Now, let's take a look at our phases of
price here. Expansion, consolidation.
So, this is where we're going to want to
see a low ran out before we want to see
a move higher. So, we can also form a
new swing point here as this candle has
no wick. We could also be looking for
price to take out this level as well.
So, here we open up. We reach into this
low. So, we could be looking for a move
higher now.
And once again, all we're looking for
now that we have confirmed the low of
the day with a swing point is just a
15-minute continuation. So, here you can
see, we did form a 15-minute
continuation with SMT. We could look to
trade that long.
Or, we could look for a retracement back
into the range to get some better risk
to reward. So, maybe taking a retest
here.
Or, we can look for a new continuation.
Let's see what it would look like with a
retest entry. Or, we can see if we get a
new continuation.
So, there's a retest. Here's a new
continuation.
And we could also take an entry there or
on the retest of that.
There's the retest of that and we get a
new continuation higher.
But, what are we really doing here?
Well, if I go ahead and click this
button here, we'll show the 4-hour chart
with the daily chart. So, with the daily
chart on there, we were just letting the
daily wick form using that 4-hour swing
point here. And then we're looking to
trade a continuation. So, we're looking
for the continuation in here, but it
already took out a target and then
consolidated. So, we're waiting for a
new continuation. This new continuation
within the daily range is actually a
reversal and we can look for another
continuation if we want to here.
But overall, what are we doing? We're
lining all these time frames together. A
candle three, and then we're also
looking to trade another candle three.
So, this is candle two here. We wanted
to trade that. Or we could wait for
another candle three there, which gives
a another two R there. So, we're just
trying to align all time frames in one
direction, then use protected swings or
the close over the series of down close
candles into a point of interest to
frame our continuations higher. So, as I
let this continue higher, you can see we
continue to get another continuation.
Candle three and four continue higher
and into the new day. So, we'll replay
that one more time to right there.
You can see our daily candle. We open.
We form a low. We trade and trend
higher. And then that forms an open low,
high close, and we're trying to find
4-hour swing points to trade away from
on our intraday time frames for the
4-hour and 15. So, here we are on
Bitcoin. So, let's see if we can find
some examples in here. You can see we
have a daily swing point formed. We form
it out of a fair value gap. We have a
candle two closure. Do we have an hourly
change in the state of delivery?
We'll go ahead, go down to the hourly
time frame here. Do we have the hourly
change in the state of delivery? We do.
So, you can see as we get into this next
day,
my model will print out a green box, and
I'll be looking for longs in this day.
Now, if I'm looking for a long setup
here in candle three, what am I going to
want to look for? A 4-hour swing point.
We're going down to the 4-hour time
frame. Do we have a 4-hour swing point
to trade away from?
Let's see if we form one.
And no, we do not get a 4-hour swing
point, right? We just create failure
swings. So, this is not something we'd
be able to trade yet. Let's go back to
our daily time frame. Has this candle
closed? It has. So, we can be looking
for price to respect this EQ if it's
going to trade higher. Once again, going
to the 4-hour time frame. So, down here
on the 4-hour time frame, do we have a
4-hour swing point? Not yet, so let's
see what happens
here on the new candle open, we reach
into this gap, and we have a candle to
closure. So, now what do we have? We
have a candle for continuation on the
daily, so we're looking for this to
trade higher. We have a 4-hour swing
point, so the next thing to do is go
down to the 15-minute time frame.
So, down here on the 15-minute time
frame,
we're just going to be looking for a
continuation to trade this higher. So,
you can see, we open up right here.
Could I just take a long set up right
here? Sure, I just need my stop down
here. Can I get 2R?
Sure.
That would be trading the reversal, and
we're fine to do that if we want to. We
can also see if we can form a
continuation, a new continuation in this
candle to form the wick of the 4-hour
time frame.
Let's see.
So, right here, we reach below these
lows.
Do we form a new continuation, which
would be a close through the series of
candles here?
Let's see.
Oh, we made a new low, so we have a new
series of candles, in this case it's
just one, and we've closed over. Now, we
can look long here, put our stop here,
and then look for 2R, which would be
right here, or I can hold until it's
higher. So, two possible entries here.
One would be a reversal, you have to
have a wider stop. One would be a
continuation, you have a smaller stop.
Let's see. This one hits our TP. Let's
see if the next one hits our TP as well.
It takes a while, but it does hit our TP
as well. So, you see both of those work.
And what are we noticing right here?
We'll go ahead and replay it just a
little bit. We are aligning a 4-hour
swing point with our daily candle,
expecting our daily candle to expand.
Once we find protected swings on the
15-minute time frame, we can look for it
to expand as well. Now, do you have to
trade an expansion candle on the daily?
No, you don't have to. It's just the
easiest, right? The easiest is going to
be aligning that candle three with a
lower time frame candle three, and then
a continuation entry. But, if you notice
right here, we could also trade this
back across the range. But, that's not
in line with the daily candle, so I
would prefer not to. You can see we have
a continuation SMT, a CISD, and we have
a small wick that supports expansion
lower. We could look for that to expand
lower. You can see it expanded lower
into this low,
right? Taking out our current day's low.
But, I would always prefer to align with
the daily time frame or with that
expansion. So, one more time, what were
we doing?
We'll clean up the chart with no
indicator. We're looking to trade an
expansion on the daily, since we had a
daily swing point at a point of interest
here with a candle two closure, and that
was paired with an hourly change in the
state of delivery. I can look to trade
this candle higher. This candle never
gave any opportunity because it didn't
make a 4-hour swing point. But, since it
closed over candle two's high, we can
expect a further continuation. So, using
the EQ of this, we'd want to see that be
respected, but we can look for a 4-hour
swing point in there. So, inside that
next daily candle,
which is right here, we have a new
4-hour swing point and a candle two
closure. So, now we have aligned our
daily expansion, which we're expecting
to go higher, with a 4-hour swing point,
and then we're taking an entry on the
15-minute time frame expecting it to go
higher.
So, here we are on our last example, and
what do we have here? We have a daily
candle two closure. Why is this ideal?
It is ideal because it is also forming a
protected swing. It's closing over the
series of down closed candles into the
low, right? Just taking out these lows
to the left. So, it is also forming a
protected swing at the same time.
So, what does this mean? We could be
looking for a candle three continuation
from the upper half of this daily range
higher. So, what would we want to do?
We'd want to look for a 4-hour swing
point.
So, let's let this open up.
What do we notice? We have price open
low first, which is ideal if we're
bullish.
Because we're forming the lower wick of
the daily candle. And what do we have? A
candle two closure.
Right? So, here we have a candle two
closure. Then we'd want to go to the
15-minute time frame.
Here on the 15-minute time frame, what
do we have? A change in the state of
delivery, which means it's valid to look
for candles to trade higher in this next
candle. What do we notice before the
open here? We notice that we have
already went into this fair value gap
and closed over these down-closed
candles. Forming a new continuation
already prior to the open. This is where
I could look to take a positional entry.
Put my stop on this low because I have a
protected swing prior to the open. And
then look for two R or hold runners to
those higher time frame objectives.
Because I'm entering around the opening
price of the daily candle, right? Right
around it or below it. If I'm expecting
price to expand, I can almost hold this
toward the close of the daily candle.
And see, we form a new continuation.
So, if you didn't get entered into this
first one, you could enter into this
next one as well.
And then we expand higher.
So, you can see, what are we doing?
We're aligning a daily expansion candle
with a 4-hour expansion candle.
And then, do we get a continuation here,
too? We also do as well. So, just to
review, you can see what did we do? We
aligned a daily candle three, where we
are expecting it to expand, with a
4-hour candle three. Then we're looking
to trade this 4-hour candle three with a
protected swing. In this case, we had
the protected swing form just prior, so
it's a positional entry, or we could
wait for another continuation within
that candle three. Then we're just
letting it expand as we're expecting
this daily candle to expand. And like I
will go over my futures targets video,
if I'm looking for a higher time frame
target and letting these run, this is
where you can get really good risk to
reward trades.
If you were looking for a way to work
more closely with me and get more
one-on-one support within your trading,
you can click the link below. We have a
waitlist for our program, so you can
join and I will let you know when we
have new openings.
But with that said, I hope you enjoyed
the video, and I'll see you guys next
time. Have a good one.